the picture that science presents to us
is is in some sense uncomfortable
because what we've learned is that we
are more insignificant than we ever
could have imagined you could get rid of
us and all the galaxies and everything
we see in the universe would be largely
the same
so we're insignificant on a scale that
Copernicus never would have imagined and
in addition it turns out the future's
miserable so the two-minute lessons that
I like to say I like to give is first
we're insignificant and second in the
future is miserable now that you might
think that should depress you but I
would argue that in fact it shouldn't in
you and and provide you a different kind
of consolation because if the universe
doesn't care about us and if we're an
accident in a remote corner of the
universe in some sense it makes us more
precious the meaning in our lives is is
provided by us we provide our own
meaning and we are here by by accidents
of evolution and and the formation of
planets and we should enjoy our brief
moment in the Sun we should make the
most of our brief moment in the Sun
because this is all we have and even if
we're so rare that were the only life
forms in the universe which I doubt that
makes us in some sense while we're more
insignificant more more special we are
endowed with a consciousness that can
ask questions about the beginning of the
universe and learn about the universe on
its largest scales and experience
everything that it means to be human
music art literature and science so for
me it should be spiritually uplifting
that we're not created with a purpose by
someone who who who takes care of us
like like a mannequin or or or with
strings determining everything we
determine our future and that makes our
future more precious
you